the last lecture of today I
will talk about graph sketching and upon
thinking okay I I will get to the
problem of finding wires in in the walls
of houses but I can't help covering
connectivity through graph sketching
because it's very cute and simple
okay so uh we will talk about the graph
streaming model of computation so I
quickly defined that for you edges of a
graph G arrive in an arbitrary order in
a stream just like that the vertices are
known to us they're numbers 1 through n
here they are shown in green the
algorithm gets a single pass over the
stream and at this point edges are just
inserted into the stream and as the
algorithm is scanning the stream we
wanted to take to use only n poly login
bits of storage so that's the space
requirement
good uh these are known as insertion
only streams edges are only inserted
into the graph
here's a very simple problem most basic
problem that I want to consider in this
setting which is construct a spanning
tree of the graph well assuming it's
connected in a single pass
okay it is extremely easy in insertion
only streams all right we're just
looking for spanning trees and just keep
coming and you know if we we store a
forest at every point in time if the new
age coming in closes a cycle we throw it
away if it doesn't we add it to our
forest that's uh and login space and
solves the problem
good so let's see how this works this
red is my Forest let's say the black
Edge comes in and I don't take it I
close the cycle
okay
wonderful so in insertion only streams
the spanning tree problem is very easy
uh fantastic now how about
streams or edges get to arrive and
depart namely Dynamic streams so streams
with Edge deletions now here the
situation seems to be significantly
harder for example look at this graph it
could be that we're observing a stream
of insertions and deletions and at some
point during the stream the graph looks
like this
uh look at this red Edge this red Edge
is crossing a cut so this Edge is
somehow critical to the connectivity of
the graph Okay so
whatever the algorithm is storing at
this point in the Stream
should be very correlated with the
presence of this red Edge the algorithm
should know about this Edge at this
point
great now we are an insertion deletion
in Dynamic stream so let me just add a
few more edges to the graph I'll add a
bunch of edges that go across the same
cut fantastic so here is the second
snapshot of the graph in the Stream now
this cut is this particular Edge this
this Edge was red this Edge is not
particularly important and for that
matter I could have added a complete
graph at this point
okay so let's uh think about it so what
does the algorithm store at this point
it seems like what the algorithm stores
at this point is not really correlated
with this red this Edge that used to be
red The Edge is unimportant aha but we
are in the dynamic streaming setting so
at the next stage I could just go and
delete all the edges that I added and
I'm back in this situation and this uh
edge here is important again
so what could we possibly store so that
we know about the presence of this Edge
exactly one it is important despite the
fact that throughout the stream the
importance may go up and down
all right so clearly very different
algorithms are needed and that's exactly
where sketching comes into play right
there's really at this point only one
generic Hammer that we have to
handle
Dynamic streaming problems and that's
make the algorithm maintain a linear
function of the Stream
good so how do we apply sketching to
create techniques to graphs how exactly
what exactly do we
risk so here's an very beautiful idea
introduced by angul a Gregor and soda
2012 and in in the same in the same
conference independently by Valerie and
the idea is to apply sketching
techniques to the edge vertex incidence
Matrix of the graph G all right so this
is the Matrix that featured prominently
in sushan's lectures here it is the
Matrix B it has and choose two rows and
N columns The Columns correspond two
vertices the rows correspond to edges or
other potential edges I I wanted to have
a fixed Dimension a row is zero for
edges for pairs of vertices that are not
an edge in the graph and if an edge UV
is in the graph then the row is non-zero
there is exactly one one and exactly one
minus one one at U minus one at V
choose the orientation of this Edge any
way you like it does not matter
all right
excellent uh good so as a stated rows
are indexed by potential edges or pairs
of vertices and if the edges on the
graph then the corresponding row is the
difference between the indicator of one
of the vertices and the indicator of the
other vertices vertex
great
so roles correspond to edges
no I'm a fan of this one
uh all right so what is the key property
of the edge incidence Matrix that we're
going to use the key property is the
following oh there's a typo there's
supposed to be a c so suppose that I'm
interested in a cut C uh in in the graph
I'm interested in the set of edges
Crossing from C to the complement of C
um
good let's X be the indicator Vector of
one side of the cut C which is the
vector of length and it has ones on
vertices that are in C and zeros
elsewhere
good key claim that we're going to use
is that be the edge incidence Matrix
times x is the indicator of the cut
oh it's it's a vector of length n choose
two I claim that it has non-zeros
exactly in edges that are in the graph
and cross the cut
the null zeros might be a one or plus
one but I don't really care which one it
is
good
[Music]
um
the proof of this claim is by picture
and this is the picture
uh suppose that I'm interested in this
cut that we considered before so the
corresponding indicator Vector is X it
is ones on these four vertices and zeros
on the on the others uh excellent now
let's consider B times x b times x is
basically the act of adding up The
Columns of B
corresponding to vertices in X so
if I consider an edge uh wait if I
consider an edge UV such that both
endpoints are in C then the one and the
minus one cancel because I add up over
all the vertices and C uh if the edge is
in is not in has both endpoints not in C
I also get a zero and if one endpoint is
NC and the other is not I get a one or
minus one switch excellent
good so how do we use this observation
to solve connectivity in Dynamic streams
so that's the result of Ang McGregor
great uh
let's start with a very natural and
simple algorithm for
connectivity for constructing connected
components and then we'll verify that
one can implement it
from a sketch
so here's our graph the algorithm will
proceed over a logarithmic number of
rounds and the algorithm will maintain
connected components in a graph of merge
them together as we go along so we start
with our collection of connected
components calligraphic c0 as containing
the singles and vertices
okay so here here they are the the green
vertices then in every round we look at
all the connected components in our
current collection and we choose one
outgoing edge with every component
chooses one outgoing image you know in
round one every verdicts shows a
neighbor so this is shown with red
arrows all right and note that it could
be that one vertex chose the other and
this vertex shows choose the other one
back or more interesting things can
happen so
okay so we do this and then we just
merge the corresponding connected
components and add add a spanning forest
on the selected edges right so the set
of selected edges could have Cycles but
we prune this so after the first round
we have a connected component of size 2
here another connected component and a
connected component of size four
excellent
we just simply do this again in the next
round every connected component chooses
one outgoing Edge so this connected
component these two vertices chosen edge
here the the red arrow this connected
component shows this Edge this shows
this
uh again merge the corresponding
connected components and add a spanning
forest on the selected edges
good now we're done in two rounds in
this particular example of course it is
not hard to verify that the number of
connected components
uh at least halves in every such round
so in order login rounds we will be done
good
now I claim that we will be able to
implement this algorithm
given a sketch of the edge vertex
incidence Matrix of our graph
why well this is because for each the
main operation in this algorithm is the
following operation we have a
set of vertices in the graph C
and our task is to choose one Edge going
from C to the complement of C now by the
key property that we
approved by a picture just a few moments
ago
choosing an edge from the cut induced by
C is the same as choosing one non-zero
element of the from the vector B times
the indicator of C
okay
and I claim that this can actually be
done using a linear sketch a
pre-computed linear sketch
um
these sketches are called l0 Samplers
and I will quickly tell you on the board
what these are
and I will not tell you how to construct
them in the interest of time it's a very
nice exercise
foreign
sampler
from l0 sampler is a sketch
it's a random Matrix with M A rows and
in this application n choose two columns
such that
for any given X
in r
and choose two
one can recover
one element
support
of x
from s times x
okay
I'm simplifying the definition a little
bit if you look up the proper definition
of l0 Samplers you'll realize that they
return a uniformly random element of X
these details are not very important for
those applications I'll simply skip them
okay so it's a sketch that returns one
element of the support of X and how many
rows does the sketch have uh well the
number of rows depends on the success
probability of the sketch but very
importantly it's poly logarithmic number
of rows if the failure probability is
inverse polynomial again the fine
details of this are not very important
good so such sketches exist
um
and can be constructed
without too much effort and in fact we
already know tight bounds on the
sketching complexity of this l0 sampling
problem so equipped with these sketches
here's how we can solve Dynamic
connectivity
um look at our algorithm that proceeds
over order login rounds and note that at
every step in this algorithm we need to
choose one Edge going across a certain
cut so what do we do we simply
pre-compute uh capital T well plus one
l0 sampling sketches and maintain
sketches as of the verdict Edge vertex
incidence Matrix b s 0 B through s t b
these matrices as 0b through stb are
very small uh the number of rows in this
Matrix is poly logarithmic that's the
number of rows in the sketch the number
of columns is an
all right so let's uh let me just draw
this uh draw this here perhaps
okay so the edge incidence Matrix was n
choose two by n we're sketching it down
we're sketching the large Dimension down
to
number of rows
so as we
go through the stream the algorithm is
maintaining n poly login bits of
information so every vertex maintains a
small poly logarithmic size sketch of
its neighborhood
great so then once
in the algorithm we need to select
a edge going across a cut C what do we
do we simply run the decoder of the l0
sample on St times B times the indicator
of C now this is well this might look
very
simple but this is where the magic is
happening in fact so
[Music]
um
somehow the challenge here the apparent
challenge is that we do not really know
which Cuts will
occur in the decoding process before we
see the graph nevertheless we were able
to pre-compute a sketch from which we
can decode the the the the the edge that
crosses the cut so what we're really
interested in is one Element one Edge
crossing the cut c as we know this is
one non-zero of B times 1C so we would
like to have an l0 sampler of B times 1C
but by linearity this is the same as the
l0 sampler of B times 1C
so despite the fact that the algorithm
is very adaptive and we don't know which
Cuts we will have to use when we decode
we're able to pre-compute
sketches that let us support any
execution path of the algebra
okay
yes and you can same sketch for all the
cuts produced at the same level
excellent question so uh anupam is
asking
um is it true that you can use the same
sketch for all the cuts at the same
level of this process the answer is yes
there are no dependencies there this is
this is very very nice
um uh good so as mentioned a similar
result was obtained by Valerie and uh
authors
um
theirs is 12. oh and I didn't even know
about this and mine wasn't a sketching
result it was a useful memory it used uh
right but the techniques are the same
the techniques look the same they didn't
they didn't I didn't think of it the
same way at all I see I see sure yeah
yours is this yours used xor right yeah
use X4 and I used it based on parity
so I have two questions about this is
are these two results equivalent and we
have to do this computation right this
looks like it's linear in the size of C
which
uh great yeah good uh so so wait the
first question was are these results
equivalent I didn't fully understand it
what do you mean yes
Valerie's result in the sketching result
they're not equivalent but they
basically discover this beautiful idea
of sketching
Valerie doesn't call it sketching but
that's what she does
okay
etching from me I wasn't trying to save
memory for me it was just understanding
that sampling would reveal the names of
the edges because a parody the parody of
the sums of the degrees
that you know you yeah so it's different
and of course mine was about the time
needed to come up with the just to get
the answer and theirs was about the
space needed yes yes yes so maybe I was
you know they're they're the same thing
from a
from a very high level right the the
main idea the beauty here is the fact
that you can do cancellations right
right and that that's the key idea the
rest is bells and whistles
all right I should stop
okay
it's a beautiful idea that's what that's
what I want that's what I had all right
and now your other question was
time to compute
community
oh no yes the time to compute this is
indeed C uh but that's great right
basically uh we look at s times B that's
a matrix with n
columns and poly logarithmic number of
rows and at every round in this process
we have some partition of the vertex set
now for every partition we just go and
add up the columns corresponding to
vertices for every element and the
partition we go and add up the
corresponding Columns of tests
of C no this is fine
the overall runtime will not be
competitive with uh algorithms that are
not streaming algorithms
because
because okay I'm sketching
concern that they weren't asking that
question yeah my album was oh
was use data structures to do it um fast
right exactly so this is this is not
about Dynamic algorithms that maintain
the solution faster and I said built and
whistles
let me just very quickly add some pizza
communities quite well so I mean in the
one sketchy Community they have it with
all the end time
and what we do in the data structures
Community is that we for example have an
Euler tour of each component we just sum
up these things
but that was just the translation
Community a linear time to the end
that's great okay which is not the case
right technology solution uses poly n
poly log bits so it's the same space
yeah so in this kitchen Community we
don't uh these results don't care about
maintaining an actual solution at all
times efficiently which was the focus of
Valerie's paper but you know I have
excellent building problems related to
exactly that I I think it should be
possible to merge the two
first all right uh good so as anupama
was asking at every level we do get to
use the same sketch but note that we do
need a separate sketch per level because
of additivity that's exactly these
issues that our guarantees what we run
the sketch on should be independent of
the randomness of the sketch foreign
connectivity problem or at least for the
distributed version of this we currently
have tight bounds so if we if you
tighten up the parameters in the
solution of Angus and McGregor that I
presented you get n log cubed n Bits of
space
and this is optimal in some senses
so I don't have a solution that uses
analog to the three uh
sorry we use that many bits sorry never
mind but the time isn't yeah
good okay so let me skip the
uh skip the lower bound discussion and
the interest of space because I would
like to talk about the spectral uh
specification question because it is
very cool so in the remaining time I'll
try to give some of the main ideas
behind
our algorithm also does the paper with
the Aaron and others that gives a
sketching
linear space sketching time a sketching
algorithm for spectrally sparsifying
graphs and also provides linear time
decoding at the end of the Stream
okay
all right so
since soshang discussed spectral
specification I'll go fast here so
there's uh not much to be carefully
explained to so we're given a graph G
and vertices and edges we want to find a
spectral sparsifier G Prime
X but what it is
um
good so so maybe let me
we all know what spectral specification
is so
sushant proved in his lectures
one way of obtaining spectral
sparsifiers of graphs is through
important sampling this is the result of
Spielman and servastua
um what one does is for every Edge in
the input graph G one computes the
effective resistance of this Edge
in the electrical Network that g is if
you think of every Edge is a unit
resistor so this is denoted by ruv
um
samples these edges
Edge proportional to the resistances
well it's proportional to the resistance
is it's something of the form you take
the resistance multiplied by a large
constant times log M by Epsilon and cap
this at one if this is more than one you
make it one you have to take that edge
good and if an edge is sampled then it's
assigned probability one over p e with
high probability As sushant proved we
get a spectral approximation to the
graph G so the laplacian L Prime of the
resulting sparse subgraph sandwiches the
laplacian of L in the positive semi
definite order
good
um good
so now again
suppose that the graph is given to us as
a stream of edge updates
now if we're dealing with insertion only
streams this is not a very difficult
problem
uh I will it's a nice exercise how to
specify graphs and polylogon space and
insertion of these streams intuitively
it makes sense because if some Edge
you maintain some sub graph of the input
graph and for example you could morally
take the next incoming Edge and measure
its importance with respect to what you
currently have
if the importance is not high
then you might want to drop the edge and
since edges only come in the Stream this
is insertion only if something was
unimportant it'll only be less important
because you're adding edges and
resistances go down
Okay so
again what I would like to understand is
what to do if you have Edge deletions
and that's a completely different
question for a similar reason edges can
be important and they look unimportant
and then they're important again
we will use linear sketching and we will
use the techniques that we designed in
lecture one namely the counts cache
primitive
as as you remember the original
applications are to data streams so
we'll take we'll take our Edge vertex
incidence of the graph here it is Matrix
B it has n choose two rows and N columns
just like in our application too
connectivity and we will left multiply
it with some carefully designed sketch
fantastic so then the space complexity
of our solution will be the number of
roses sketch times the number of
vertices in the graphs will maintain a
small Matrix every vertex maintains a
poly logarithmic size summary of its own
neighborhood right I recall that
basically for vertex the column of the
corresponding column of the
Edge vertex incident Matrix encodes the
neighborhood
vertices sketched their neighborhoods
and
good
and the question that we want to resolve
is how do we design a small sketch from
which a spectral sparsifier of the graph
can be reconstructed and reconstructed
quickly
all right so let's first
let's first figure out how we would do
it if we
didn't care about the Reconstruction
time I just want a small sketch from
which a spectral sparsifier can be
reconstructed quickly
so somehow I'm supposed to well I will
Implement effective resistance sampling
but there's a challenge because I don't
know the graph so I don't really know
the effective resistances
and I need to sample with probability is
proportional to those
okay let's look at the simplest possible
setting recall that we sample edges with
probabilities proportional to effective
resistance and the constants of
proportionality is some kind of a login
Factor
so edges whose resistances are large say
larger than one over log n they need to
be with probability one added to the
sparsifier
Okay so
let's understand
how to solve a simpler problem
I want to design some kind of a sketch
such that from this sketch
I'm able to recover the high effective
resistance edges I don't care
it'll be fine
fine good
so this is our goal
design some sort of a sketch s of poly
or the poly logarithmic number of rows
from which we can recover the high
effective resistance edges of G
okay
now this problem by itself actually is a
little too hard
so I'll give myself more of a hint
the hint will be the following besides
the sketch of the graph that I want to
approximate sexually
I'll assume that I'm also given
explicitly
accrued spectral sparsifier of G what is
crude a factor 10. so I'm given
explicitly a small n poly login number
of edges graph whose laplacian L
specially approximates uh my laplacian
up to factor 10.
don't ask me where I get it from I'll
tell you later
good and now this problem already has a
nice solution so let me tell you what
this solution is
good we need to find the High effective
resistance edges so let's recall from
sushant's lecture what that actually
means what does it mean for an edge to
have high effective resistance well the
resistance between a pair vertices u and
v
is the following object or what is what
is this
uh it's the
voltage difference across u and v that
is induced by the experiment of
injecting one unit of current at U and
taking it out at V this is exactly what
this formula computes uh L inverse times
buv gives us the vertex potentials the
voltages on
um on the vertices that will result in
flow with demands buv
demand b u v remembers just minus one at
U and plus one at V that's exactly the
experiment of taking out uh one unit at
the V and injecting it
right so so that's these are the
voltages and this the transfers just
measures the difference The Crossing
okay fine that's what resistances are
fantastic here is a picture that goes
along with this let's say here's an edge
of pretty high effective resistance and
here are some voltages
I was sending a unit of current from
here to here
good
um
now
if Phi is a vector of vertex potentials
then the flow the electrical flow
induced by these potentials is just the
differences the flow on an edge X Y is
just a difference of Phi Y and v x
good to know
so basically the edge vertex into
incidence Matrix right multiplied by the
vector of vertex potentials
is the flow vector
now this gives us in fact another
characterization of effective resistance
the effective resistance of an edge UV
is the
fraction of L2 squared Norm or the
energy
of electrical flow
unit electrical flow from U to V that
sits on this Edge
so if the resistance of an edge is large
1 over log n
this means that this Edge contributes a
non-negligible fraction of the energy of
dissipates a non-negligible fraction of
the Heat
that is dissipated by the entire flow
network if you inject one current at you
and take it out it will you assuming
unit text
yes everything is here
good
very nice
uh so given this so this we don't know
currently we don't know at this point
how to use but this is a good uh
characterization of effective resistance
for us
here's how we will use it
let's design
a test parameter so remember I was
telling you that you're standing in
front of the wall of in your house and
you get to hook up the batteries and
send flow from one point to the other
we're designing this experiment now
you're given a sketch of the graph G and
the crude Spotify and now you you have a
pair u and v and you want to know
whether UV is an edge of high effective
resistance
if it's an edge of flow effective
resistance you don't care you only need
to know if it's a high effective
resistance Edge
here is the ideal thing that you want to
do is exactly the experiment that I
described you go and hook up the battery
and you send the unit of current
and then you check if the edge heats up
sufficiently well
okay uh how do you check this well you
sort of might want to form the flow
Vector in F by taking the edge incidence
Matrix right multiplying it by the
vertex potentials maybe this is the
vector and let's say right now I'm
testing this Edge so it contributes a
lot of heat it's a high effective
resistance Edge you have a large number
there
right now it's a nice experiment but of
course you can't do this in streaming
because you don't know the graph you
can't perform the flow vector
good but uh oh yes and if the edges are
non-edged then you get a zero
but
note that we don't have
um
very we don't need to answer very
fine-grained questions about this Vector
it's a very long Vector but all the that
we need is whether a given chord is to
know whether a given coordinate in this
Vector contributes a one over log n
fraction of the total energy
as we'll see in a moment this is exactly
what you can do with count sketch so
that's what we did in in lecture one so
this will be solved with counter sketch
good we'll do this in a second there is
another problem here the other problem
is that as stated in the experiment I
say oh I will compute the correct vertex
potential so I send the right flow of
course I don't really know the graph L
the graph G so I can't compute the right
vertex potentials remember I assumed
that I also have a crude spectral
sparsifier of My Graph as a hint
I'll send the flow there and use the
same potentials and this will work it is
fine it's not necessarily a flow then
but it's fine
good uh so to summarize
what we want to do is to run this
experiment of hooking up a battery
ideally we would like to if we knew the
graph we would form the flow vector and
test if the pair UV contributes a large
fraction of L2 squared Norm can't do
this but
in order to be able to figure out if a
given coordinate contributes a large
fraction of L2 squared Norm you don't
need to know the entire Vector it's
enough to know a sketch and specifically
account sketch so this question with
parameter Ada is solved by a count
sketch all that we need to do is Hash
into something poly logarithmic number
of buckets and do our repetitions I will
not do this very precisely here as long
as we hash the flow Vector of length n
choose 2 into a poly logarithmic number
of buckets we will be able to get
approximations to individual entries
that are more precise than one over poly
log n fraction of the total L2 squared
Norm
and that means that we'll be able to
know if a given Edge is a high effective
resistance Edge in the graph
okay
so this is just for one age no this is
just for one Edge
yes
please continue
to for every Edge yes so right now we're
doing a very slow solution we'll try
every pair
every pair you viewed basically right
now I don't care about run
I just want to convince myself that I
can at least have a small sketch of the
graph
that I can indicate
so let me Define the sketch and then
we'll see if this generates a question
basically this is my algorithm for this
problem at the moment
I will take a sketch s which is the
count sketch with some poly logarithmic
number of buckets
and my
my algorithm is going to maintain as the
edges come in
s times B The Edge incidence Matrix of
my graph
okay so what is this this is a matrix of
roughly this shape the poly logarithmic
number of rows and and columns
so now I look at this Matrix I have my
crude sparsifier and you give me a pair
of vertices and you say okay tell me if
this pair UV is an edge of high
effective resistance in the graph
what do I do I take my crude sparsifier
I wrote a flow from U to V there this
gives me some vertex of potential see
then I take this Matrix that I have and
I right multiply it by Phi
this one is better
okay so I'm storing s times B which is
Matrix like this this is a poly log
by n
all right so then given
u and v i compute some Vector of
potentials these are the potentials that
induce a unit UV flow and some graph
that is similar to mine
and then I look at s times B times Phi
and then what will happen is that this
is Again by this magic of linear algebra
is s times B times Phi
yeah I'll do this offline at decoding
stage all right now this this object
here is what this object here is
actually the flow vector
so I have a sketch of the flow vector
and then I go and check if corresponding
coordinate is large
all right
um any other questions
thank you this is great so
uh fantastic so basically every vertex
every vertex computes such as sketch and
here's the the same equations on the
slide right so now uh we have UV we
compute the potentials V
um okay and then we
um
by Magic of linear algebra by
associativity get access to the sketch
of B times C
yeah sorry we're probably missing
something how did you we have not yet
checked that this is an edge in the in
the original graph uh
okay you're saying we haven't checked
that this is an edge in the original
graph making the stream right no we
don't know that we don't know that we're
trying to check and we can't know if
this was an edge maybe this was a low
effective resistance Edge
I just don't have enough information I
understand but but yours you could fix
you you could find a pair that has high
effective resistance but was not an edge
yes in the graph such Affairs definitely
exist but then if you form the
corresponding flow vector
all right in the actual graph G and look
at how much energy the entry UV entry
corresponding to that pair contributes I
see you'll see a small number it'll be
zero actually
The Edge is not there so there will
actually be zero you will not know that
it's zero because you don't know the
entire flow Vector but you have a count
sketch and the count sketch tells you
that whatever it is it's much smaller
than one of a poly log fraction of the
total energy thank you
you could also do the case parts are
covering to see if it's in the list
right uh
I think so nothing is sparse here right
Decay Heavy Hitters it has to be a if oh
yes exactly exactly sorry so just you
okay Heavy Hitters and it has to be one
of them yes you can do that right
exactly and you can either think of
talent sketch as just approximating the
values that's good enough or you can
think of
we didn't really cover algorithms for
how to generate the list of heavy
heaters fast
enough yeah
uh perfect
good so that's what we do uh wonderful
and well this is great
ah so this as of now we designed this
test
we know that the act of hooking up a
battery to uh to Junction points on the
wall of your house this corresponds to
testing whether the energy of some
electrical flow is mostly contributed by
the pair UV
good
and this already gives us a low space
sketch that
you can decode in the quadratic type
of course there are details we've only
explained how to find the heavy
resistance edges but it's okay
all right so now let's design a fast
decoding output I have this sketch of
size and poly login but if you ask me to
decode it I'll start trying all pairs of
vertices that's not nice let's do a
linear number of tests
before you do that yes
you haven't told us how to get rid of
the Assumption or no that's recursion
you'll see I didn't tell you uh
maybe now is a good time all right so
how do you get rid of so uh General's
question was how do you get rid of the
assumption that you have a large
constant Factor approximation to your
graph I don't want to tell you about
this because I only have 15 minutes and
I want to cover the fast element I'll
tell you later okay okay good exercise
[Laughter]
good so we have the cement a hook up the
battery to the endpoints great
uh and yeah so you see if an edge is
high effective resistance like this Edge
is high effective resistance then it
lights up it contributes a lot of heat
if you hook up a battery to an edge that
is low effective resistance it doesn't
light up uh all the flow goes many ways
and the amount of heat contributed by
this particular Edge is low it's a small
fraction
good
so then uh yeah so this is my
interpretation with finding wiring in a
house so let me show you this picture at
least
um
yeah the the the circuit is from XKCD
the dots are from me
they're actually more than 70 dots in
this picture I think I got to 50 and
then it was hard to stop
anyway so so this is the situation right
so you have the vertices and then you
can attach a battery and then feel the
very hot edges great
um so let's see how to do this
um
so suppose that there is an SUV that is
a high effective resistance Edge and we
need to find it
so far we only know that it will light
up if we hook up the battery to u and v
save on the number of tests we need to
find a different characterization of
edges of high effective resistance we
would like to find another pair a b and
V another pair of vertices such that
UV will light up it will carry a lot of
energy
carry a good fraction of a b flow send
flow from A to B and UV suddenly shows
up all right if we manage to do that
then we we have a shot it will be
[Music]
um
formally what does this mean and so I'll
give you the full proof
because this proof is very very short
and clean so let me try to go slowly and
really be formal
what does it mean for UV to carry a lot
of a b flow so that we can detect it
well
let Tau be the vertex potentials induced
by the corresponding a b flow
cell inverse times b a b as social tools
explaining
then the amount of flow on the edge UV
is just a difference of potentials
so the energy is the difference of
potential squared
and then
our countenance cage primitive only
detects
uh edges that are large in relative
terms so we care about the total the
contribution of this Edge relative to
the total energy of the flow the total
energy of the a b flow is actually the
effective resistance from A to B
that's another fact
good
so that's the condition that we need we
need to find a pair a b such that
the potential distance squared across UV
divided by resistance of between A and B
is still roughly 1 over log n
good
um
what is one over log n really what we
mean is that
it should be roughly the ratio
roughly the fraction of energy that UV
contributes in its own electrical flow
and that fraction is what is Phi U minus
VV fear the UV potentials divided by
resistance of UV
good
um
yes let's skip these examples let's
to find such a pair a b we will use
something that
some of us may have learned in high
school
in electrical networks classes and this
is known as the reciprocity theorem the
reciprocity theorem says that the
potential difference
induced on a pair
a b
uh by sending a unit of current from U
to V is the same as the potential
difference induced on UV when you send a
unit of current from A to B so you can
reverse the experiment
mathematically this is just the symmetry
of certain expression that we'll see
um okay so suppose we send the UV flow
UV flow results in potentials fee that's
l through the inverse times buv good
a b flow results in potentials Tau
that's L to the inverse times b a b
um
then the potential difference
across UV
in the a b experiment is buv transpose
Tau so that's buv transpose L inverse b
a b
the potential difference on a across a b
induced by the UV flow
is just the transpose of that it's b a b
times V so you just transpose this
expression to transpose a number it's
the same thing so that's the proof of
the reciprocity theorem
all right so why is this useful
um
why is this useful so we're trying to
find this pair a b that will carry a
good such that UV carries a good
fraction of a b flow
um
so let's look at the UV experiment
what and fee are the Potentials in the
UV
experiment
when you send a unit of flow from U to V
the minimum potential will be at U the
maximum at V and everybody else will be
in the middle
so here's the picture that goes along
with this all the other vertices are
somehow in the middle this is U this is
V and these are all the other vertices
of the graph
so we call this the potential embedding
of u and v that's an embedding of the
vertices of the graph induced by
sending a unit of flow from U to V
okay
good
so let's look at this expression again
so c u minus CV is sort of large
right we start with the assumption that
UV is a high effective resistance Edge
so the potential difference between CU
and VV is large
um
if we look at this potential embedding
well we realize that for any vertex X
c u minus VV here's X is in Black can be
written as v u v minus v x and then plus
v x minus VV we can split the potential
difference as from U to X and then from
X to V excellent
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take X
to be a Vertex that is not too close uh
sorry sorry for for every vertex uh
um
take X and look at the one of the
vertices u and v will be kind of far
from X X can't be close to both so
potential difference you know X to one
of the endpoints will be at least a half
of the potential potential difference
from U to V and so the experiment that
we will be running is the experiment of
sending flow from X to the endpoint that
is far enough from X
that's what we will apply the
reciprocity theorem
let me just do this here
so consider the experiment of sending
flow from X this middle vertex really
think that it's in the middle to U
let Tau be the corresponding potential
what's the potential difference across u
and v in this XU experiment
uh well by the reciprocity theorem it's
the same as the potential difference
from U to X in the UV experiment
right
but we know that the potential
difference from U to X and U the
experiment is large
X is in the middle
or rather we can choose X to be we can
choose U to be the further of the two
pairs from X
so this is excellent we already found an
experiment X to U
for which the potential difference
on UV
is comparable
at least a quarter of the potential
difference
across UV in uv's own experiment
wonderful
all right so it seems like we're done
and really all that we did is use the
reciprocity theorem
um
so are we done is it true that if I take
the X to U
flow then the edge UV will contribute a
good fraction of the energy
not quite
okay because it has to be relative
right so the potential difference is
high enough
but there is a denominator we normalize
by the energy of the flow there's
basically one problem remaining
so we made sure that
difference in potentials is at least
there's a difference in potential
squares squared is at least a quarter of
the UV difference
squared
but the normalization is different here
we're normalizing by the
energy of the UV flow
whereas here we're normalizing by the
energy of the X U flow
all right
so all that we need to ensure is that
the distance from X to U
in resistance metric
is not too high is comparable to the
distance from U to V
okay and once we do that we're done
so let me just put this together into
the algorithm and
I think I need five minutes from here
and we will really have the algorithm
so here here is the here's the
experiment
so to discover an Edge UV
with effective resistance
whose effective resistance is large I'm
trivially large
here's what we're going to do
um
we're going to choose some vertex X
that is not too far from in the
resistance metric from U
H resistance is at most poly log
then we will send flow from X to U
and list all the heavy edges in that
flow
and then it will send flow from X to V
list all the heavy edges
and that flow
by what we just said
the SUV will be in one of the lists
because remember the thing that we
needed from X
well only the two things X is not too
far from the endpoints of u and v
and the second part that we needed was
that in the potential embedding of u and
v
X
should be the experiment that succeeds
is the one that corresponds to the
further endpoint so if we try both u and
v one of the experiments will succeed
all right uh fantastic so uh that's a
that's a nice experiment but how do we
turn it into an actual algorithm with a
linear or nearly linear runtime
complexity
uh we take the vertices of the graph and
we want to partition them into clusters
of bounded effective resistance diameter
okay so here's a pictorial
representation of that then for every
such cluster in the partition we perform
the following operation we pick one
representative vertex X here's X
and we try these flow experiments from X
to every other vertex in the cluster so
that's a linear number of experiments
vertex in the cluster it's one exponent
by our analysis
any Edge UV that is heavy
and who's such that both endpoints are
in the cluster will light up in one of
the experiments and we will find it
so the only way that this approach fails
is that our SUV has
the two endpoints in different clusters
and then it could somehow happen that
the representative
uh in the in use cluster that we pick is
somehow too close to you in the
corresponding potential embedding in the
same review that would be the disaster
so we need to we need to ensure one
other property which is that we don't
cut heavy effective resistance edges
so why will this property be satisfied
and for that I need to remind you what
the resistive embedding is uh the
resistive embedding uh covered that but
uh basically
um the resistive embedding is a map that
sends vertices of any graph into
euclidean space actually and choose
two-dimensional euclidean space such
that the effective resistance between u
and v is the square of the euclidean
distance
between these vertices
it's great that effective resistance is
the square of a euclidean metric
and now we can of course with this
observation we can
State our final algorithm we construct
the resistive embedding one can
construct it after some dimensionality
reduction we use John's London Styles
because it's a euclidean metric one can
compress it very efficiently uh then
we formed this partition if the vertices
using locality sensitive hashing style
techniques you can just use locality
sensitive hashing now this will have the
property that
an edge UV
such that u and v are close in euclidean
distance will not be cut too often by
the partition randomized partition that
results and therefore everything will be
great so and locality sensitive hashing
there's this notion of a near distance
and we'll set it to 1 which is there is
basically roughly the resistance that
we're looking for and so edges are
seldom cut the given Edge is cut by a
given partition with only one over
polyblock probability so this leads to a
very efficient time
good uh so let me pretty much end here
except I would like to mention
a couple of open problems
so first there's a very interesting open
problem
the slow recovery primitive that I
described to you before
the one that takes a quadratic number of
tests actually also extends to matrices
one can
takes more time to Define this but one
can recover not just graphs but spectral
approximations to matrices this way our
speed up the fast method does not extend
to General matrices we really use the
structure of vertices
um and it would be nice to find more
applications on this uh so this I will
not
talk about
one very exciting direction that I would
like to pursue is is related to our
previous discussion on Dynamic versus
versus sketching
can one turn
sketching algorithms into Dynamic
algorithms by basically saying following
so
here I I gave you an algorithm for
maintaining a spectral sparsifier using
a and poly login space and I also showed
you how to decode it in end time
wouldn't it be nice to look at this
sketch and directly prove so to speak
stability bounds
um I can
in Dynamic algorithms one wants to
always maintain an explicit solution so
what I could do is just at every step of
of the process I could redecode my
sketch this of course would take end
time per step and that's not very nice
but on the other hand how different are
the sketches across for neighboring
graphs
that seems like a very interesting
question it's prove that sketches are
stable and the outputs of discussions
are also stable if if that is
successfully done then we'll have a nice
hammer for turning low space sketching
algorithms into Dynamic algorithms would
be fantastic all right thanks for your
attention
[Applause]
thank you questions
did you do that for the last problem the
last thing you talked about did you try
to make it into a dynamic algorithm oh I
I tried
um not not very very hard
um I couldn't but but I but I think one
should try harder
so there's some very interesting
questions uh even basic questions that
arise here for instance I mentioned that
in order to do the decoding we need to
explicitly maintain the resistive
embedding right and basically you should
just know what the resistance resistance
is between vertices are right I don't
know
this resistive embedding is an embedding
of early season to log n dimensional or
so space all right basic question uh can
one maintain this embedding uh one Edge
in the graph changes so suppose you had
a JL version of the resistive in England
one Edge in the graph changes can you
quickly see what's going on there
under deletions that sounds
it sounds really intense my ignorance is
this known for spine tree so you could
use n polyloga in space and insertion
deletion screen and maintain poly lock
corruptly amortized or is this just open
so in principle this is doable it's just
not clear how it interacts with runtime
if I follow it correctly right right no
but Valerie this is exactly what for
these costs so your paper
so to clarify the opening question is
something analogous for specials
exactly or an easier question for cut
support
you know
but this stuff you could spend time for
querying right you don't have a dynamic
algorithms you don't have to have like
an explicit representation
so no I don't understand actually
you could spend time to answer a query
like you don't have to do it in o1 it
doesn't have to be you look it up right
it's explicitly there you could compute
something that would give you the query
if you could do it quickly that would
answer a query okay
well when things change and you want to
know you know you might have some
representation which will well you have
to Define what a query would be in this
case oh a query to you is delete an edge
no that would be an update a query would
be I don't know is this Edge
and you know some question that you that
you're using it is
essentially you could ask for the query
not return like meeting to maintain an
entire spanning tree but answering
connectivity or like presence of an edge
yeah yeah or is this Edge in the middle
of a Spanish tree maybe you don't have
the exact list of edits maybe you just
ask you process it it takes
plug-in time to figure it out log
squared and time to figure it out right
yeah that's the difference
an intermediate version something is
have to worry about this adaptivity or
oblivious adversary because it query can
ask which edges are there then you're
going to this group very quickly
so for now I'm I I want a problem that
is oblivious okay because making
sketches adaptive is a whole new thing
right but I find it very compelling to
just say obviously
right just maintain the solution in
small space and also explicitly on the
side
any more questions
yeah yeah I'm back yeah
so for forget spectral uh for cuts
parsifiers maybe it's easier the answer
to
sort of
it says what do you mean I mean I guess
how do you do this
probably use some recursion to yeah oh
let me do it for spectral because it's
very beautiful uh and it's a quick so
basically it's a beautiful idea from
Miller and Tang a paper called I think
on the Edition and removal of artificial
bases uh so as I said right we have a
sketch of the of our graph and then we
want to have a crude sparsifier of our
graph like a factory
five specify or ten on the side
explicitly
how do we achieve this now we don't just
go and specify G straight away we
consider a sequence of graphs uh take G
and regularize it add a Lambda times
complete graph to it right well land is
a parameter so for example when Lambda
is 1 then
um you know then the complete graph is a
good approximation to this graph so you
have your crude sparsifier already
so you can
sparsify this graph by having a
specifier of the complete graph in hand
which you do
right so then you consider G Plus Lambda
by 2. times the complete graph once you
have specified this
now this is a factorial tool three two
times one plus Epsilon spectral
approximation to this so you first
decode this guy then you specify this
once you have an explicit sparsifier of
this
you consider Lambda by 4 and once you
get to Lambda by N squared or something
of this nature it's pretty much G so
yeah it's very very cool idea
I think it's also called the homologous
rate
let's give a big round of applause
directions
that's it for the schedule today we'll
be back as usual tomorrow at 9 00 a.m uh
for coffee and the talks will be at 9 30
on optimization
you also